the first face to face and elbow to
elbow
meet him between these two men
partners side by side and not just with
their respective spouses
a new version of an old relationship but
partnerships take work and this one no
different
renewing their vows with the new version
of the 1941 atlantic charter
the original documents still here this
was the beginning
yeah no this is very not just in nato
but of the united nations yeah no i know
and the special relationship their
predecessors forged
still matters the pm keen to accommodate
his closest ally
wow well it's a great great pleasure
mr president to welcome you to call it's
a great pleasure to be here
i told the prime minister we have
something in common
we both married way above our state yeah
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do
i'm not gonna descend from that one i'm
not gonna disagree with the president
or indeed on anything else but they do
disagree
this special relationship off to a bumpy
start
an irish american president bring into
this bilat
his deep concerns over the peace process
urging the uk
not to inflame tensions in northern
ireland over new brexit trading rules
rules the uk agreed to that it's now
threatening to ignore
the pm keem to get on and move on this
summit about pursuing common goals
one thing we absolutely all want to do
and that is to uphold
the good friday at the belfast friday
agreement and and make sure we keep
the balance of the of the peace process
going and that's
absolutely common ground and you know
i'm i'm i'm optimistic that we can do
that
calm on the surface but the u.s has
sharply rebuked the uk
government behind closed doors but now
determined to pull in the same direction
prime minister johnson and i had a very
productive meeting
we discharged and discussed the broad
range of issues on which the united
kingdom and the united states are
working
in very close cooperation we affirmed
the special relationship as it's not
said lightly the special relationship
between our people
i'm told the mood music between these
two leaders behind closed doors was good
and the words after the meeting were
certainly warm from both sides
but president fired an extracting
promises too
getting mr johnson to commit to
resolving the northern ireland question
it's what brussels and dublin wanted to
hear
and it's a pledge that washington will
expect london to keep
the special relationship blooming but
with strings attached
the official summit kicks off tomorrow
with world leaders focusing on the
values they share
and the threats they share too beth
rigby's sky news cornwall